[Applaudissements]
bah oui jürgen arrête de me suivent
partout sans déconner on dirait de
connard salue les deux connards qu'est
ce que je te dis c'est pas de ma faute
d'eric d'eric postec pour l'anc est
assez psar tech
ouais ouais star trek tu marche vraiment
sur l'eau en ce moment tu devrais
demander une augmentation ou là c'est
fini et tu sais tu as he is o'conner de
jürgen colombo il prend cette fois ce
que je crois je mérite une augmentation
c'est jeudi j'appelle le pratiquent le
long de manon le vendredi c'est shabbat
déry qui bossent pas le surlendemain
alors d'eric vous voulez mort way à la
poste au tarn a ici film what on espère
est ce que tu veux boire une bora non
merci
mais venons en au fait que voulez vous
bon tu connais j'ai pas parlé d'argent
je trouve ça vulgaire
voilà entre le loyer et la crds et de la
bm je m'en sors fin à la fin du mois de
mai soit l'eau en plus j'ai ma vie
shoshana qu'a voulu la dernière cooper
de sa race qu'est-ce qu'il a fait dire
est qu est ce qu il a fait des risques
il a pris la dernière coupure et où elle
a pris la dernière cooper vrai de vrai
et les super joli hein j'ai un peu plus
manque jusqu'à me ramène un goya la
maison à mort a tout fait celle-là
bon vous voulez quoi là dieu bénisse
j'ai fait une belle année avec l'autre
connard de joergen on a résolu deux
affaires c'est pourquoi je voudrais une
augmentation bon ok d'eric je vais voir
ce que je peux faire chaud crâne à un
organe ya plus de pq d'eric téléphone
pour toi c'est le patron ou amputer ses
noces et d'airé d'eric van moer pour ce
que vous m'avez demandé
ne vous êtes complètement fou quoi même
footballeur gagne pas ça et côte moi
bien ta race de pdg ta race ou tout
moment où je débarque et je te fous dans
une boîte
je prends tes glaoui en photo et je
l'aimé on paye chaumont facebook qui a
compris mais vous ne faites pas peur
d'eric je suis ceinture jambes de judo
j'arrive ta tête jean fatah j ai pas du
long d'eric il n'y est pas allé de main
morte est le patron ouais prend bien ses
coups y apprend bien ses couilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]